[Musique]
de nombreuses recettes existent pour
accommoder le poulet aujourd'hui nous
vous proposons un plat qui sera bientôt
d'actualité
le poulet mexique vous découperez votre
poulet achèterait des épis de maïs il en
existe surgelés les ingrédients pour
préparer une marinade vin rouge huile
d'olive 2 oignons et 2 échalotes du sel
et du poivre de cayenne et pour préparer
une pâte à frire
prévoyez de la farine un oeuf de l'huile
et un verre de bière
[Musique]
vous ferez donc mariner pendant 12
heures vos morceaux de poulet dans la
préparation confectionnait comme vous la
voyez dans une jatte où vous avez versé
un demi litre de vin rouge a ajouté 4
cuillérées à soupe d'huile d'olive salez
et poivrez
[Musique]
éplucher et couper en morceaux les deux
oignons et les deux échalotes
[Musique]
mélangez bien le tout avant de placer
les morceaux de poulet qui marinent rang
pendant 12 heures
nous vous l'avons déjà dit
[Musique]
le lendemain à préparer la pâte à frire
composé de 250 g de farine d'une
cuillerée à soupe d'huile et d'un oeuf
entier
[Musique]
ajoutez pour terminer un verre de bière
vous obtenez une pâte lisse un peu
liquide dans laquelle vous mettrez les
morceaux de poulet 1 à 1 après les avoir
bien écouté au sortir de la marina
[Musique]
vous pouvez maintenant les plonger dans
la friture ou vous les laisserez cuire
10 à 15 minutes
pendant ce temps vous préparez la
garniture qui accompagnera le poulet des
épis de maïs
plongez les encore gelé dans de l'eau
bouillante salée
vous les laisserez cuire 8 minutes à feu
doux
[Musique]
il vous restera à sortir les morceaux de
poulet de la friture et les épis de maïs
de l'eau
[Musique]
et préparez vos assiettes séparément
fixez des brochettes à chaque extrémité
de la bible est ce que vous disposerez à
côté du morceau de plus est décoré avec
du persil
[Musique]
vous pouvez servir ce plat avec de la
sauce tomate
[Musique]